And he's a part of that lifestyle too.
Right.
But in a weird way,
he's a weird part of that lifestyle.
It's never been a jewel.
That jewelry you seen isn't,
they're not really don't on,
I mean like,
but he's big on design and Ferrari's and Lamborghini's and beautiful houses and
showing her that I'm aware of like wedding.
I know design.
Yeah.
No,
I know just from what I know of him that he longs to be Ralph Lauren,
but that's really has,
you know,
probably like if you said who is your biggest influence or who would you want to
be?
Ralph Lauren.
Yeah.
That's kind of hilarious.
But he just loves design.
Right?
Loves clothes,
I guess.
Yeah.
I mean,
why not somebody gotta I mean he knows all that stuff he was doing was looking
like homeless people's clothing in.
It was like Daryl leaked right out of fucking sue lender.
Did you see that one video?
The picture that Jamie showed me,
he was walking around with slides,
easy slides on,
but there were like four sizes too small.
It didn't make any sense.
He's like heels hanging off the back of them.
That's the way he designed it.
Exactly.
That's like he's probably trying to push a new thing.
He's like here,
tiny,
easy slides.
Too small for your feet to small Yeezy slides.
There you go.
Yeah,
that's the new look.
Like he,
you know,
if you're crazy,
you might think things like that.
That's crazy to me because there's an era of his career that I look at it and
I'm like,
wow man,
there's a lot of genius shit.
He was doing musically,
a lot of records he was doing.
And then,
I don't know what it is,
but to me,
to me now,
and I don't say this really in a judgmental way,
but he's a professional troll now.
And just like that's the most successful people in the,
in the entertainment business now,
if you're not an amazing actor or a super amazing,
you know,
whatever is like just keeping people troll.
And I remember he literally dropped a song like at some point like eight months
ago where that was like poop scoop,
scoop it.
He pooped,
he boop,
boop.
The scoop buddy.
Whoop.
And that was the song.
It lasted that long.
Yeah.
Jamie came in and played it for me.
I already told me the lyrics.
I can shut the fuck up.
No,
but it's like,
it's again,
it's the spectacle,
Jamie,
you stop putting this evil in my head,
it's the spectacle.
Like,
I mean,
I mean I made this album here.
That's music.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
This is music.
Lot of people don't give a fuck anymore.
Well,
you're not that guy.
You've never been a,
I need publicity guy.
Well,
here's what it is.
Here's what that is.
It's like people like to fucking speculate about what I do or my career.
You know what I mean?
I've written a few songs in this life that I could go somewhere and sit down and
just sit on a fucking stump and eat food for the rest of my life.
I'd never worry.
You know what I mean?
I could feed my family and all that off of a few songs.
I make music because I love making music,
you know?
And of course you want people to listen.
You want fucking the more people you know you want people you want,
but I don't,
I'm not,
I'm not.
Again,
one of the first things is the first time I ever came on your podcast was like,
I like going around gifts and sitting at the olive bar and fucking getting my
all lives while my songs playing on the radio and the guys standing right next
to me.
I had no fucking idea.
I don't that at all.
That doesn't bother me.
I love it.
Yeah,
you're not a need attention kind of a guy and some people are in that sort of
part of their business.
Like it's this whole Kanye Donald Trump thing.
I just,
I wonder if that's trolling,
but I also wonder if what we were talking about earlier about car accidents and
brain damage.
I wonder if that's partly a little bit of everything,
but also the reason I,
I I,
I say it's trolling is because there's
likes and stuff.
When you get to car Dash-in Kanye west levels of,
and I'm sure you know this just,
you have four fucking million Instagram followers.
I didn't start Instagram until you told me to.
I know that,
but what I'm saying is like
you could monetize that shit really easily.
Those 4 million people,
you're not that.
You're not selling that shit out.
These people,
they are definitely monetize and I should fucking,
when Kim cartilage and gets on there,
she doesn't give you a commercial,
but she'll tell you all,
I'm just using this new cream on my shit.
You know what I mean?
Here,
somebody paid her a hundred fucking 50 grand for that post.
You know?
It's like that's,
that's so the more eyes the better.
That's really what they're monetizing is like I can,
if I had 10 million people on my Instagram,
I could sell fucking posts.
The real problem with that is people don't believe them.
You know,
like you,
but their eyes are still on.
I,
if I say I like something,
it's because I like it.
Yeah.
Like if if,
and this is,
people accuse me of having an ads,
I never had a single ad on Instagram.
If I tell people about a product and people like,
what do you do?
You getting paid for this?
Like,
nope.
Nope.
Not just like it.
Yeah.
Sharon,
sorry.
I thought you might think is cool.
It's a cool,
I've done it a few times,
but I usually say,
hey,
I'm not getting fucking paid.
I'm just telling you now.
I do now because it is not,
I like this.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Plus I ain't got enough Instagram followers to get back
January.
They need,
Jamie was saying you need 70,000 that's the number.
First of all,
I said,
I don't,
you know,
I don't.
Yeah,
I know you don't give a fuck.
But if you did,
if you were a chick with a fake,
but you might be able to get a little,
I might have 4 million followers.
Yeah.
You might write,
you might have 20 look at this.
Kim Kardashians got 118 million followers.
Good googly McGlynn.
Okay.
And let's say,
what did they say?
If you're,
if you're actually good at social media,
maybe 10% of your audience engages you.
So that's still 10 million people that will engage with her.
It's a lot of fun people.
Fun.
I believe I threw that number out there and just kinda sounds about right.
Yeah.
A lot of God damn people.
Woo.
Yeah.
It's a weird businessman.
It's famous now,
like when we were young,
famous was,
you know,
if you're on TV or the radio or you know,
movies,
if you did something in life,
I wrote a book,
wrote a play or a movie,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Invented the plane and that's what got you favorites.
Now you just got to keep eyes on you doing fucked up shit.